also was nun gibt es jetzt
quantencomputer oder nicht und wenn ja
was können sie immer wieder gibt es
kommentare unter meinen videos die sich
fragen ob quantencomputer überhaupt
existieren und ob sie funktionieren also
hier der stand der quantencomputer und
welche probleme es noch gibt in der
klicks um edition zukunft rowohlt klicks
umsatzentwicklung hier gibt es drei mal
pro woche spannende wissenschafts videos
abonniert den gala- und aktiviert die
glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen
quantencomputer rechnen in der super
position darum geht es in einem kapitel
in meinem neuen buch bei aufzügen den
weltraum und in diesem buch geht es um
unsere zukunft um realistische szenarien
wie sie aussehen könnte
was also warum mit ziemlicher sicherheit
passieren wird das begründe ich
wissenschaftlich der link zum buch der
ist hier unter mir aber am ende habe ich
noch dazu eine ganz besondere bitte in
diesem video geht es um das quanten
computing und welche ungeahnten
möglichkeiten ist bietet und auf der
anderen seite welche probleme es noch
gibt in einer kurzgeschichte von
stanislaw lem dem jules verne des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts versucht ein
forschungsteam mit einem absolut
überlegenen supercomputer dem rätsel des
humors auf die spur zu kommen warum
reagieren menschen auf diese besondere
weise auf bestimmte geschichten woher
kommt dieses phänomen des lachens der
verdacht es handelt sich um ein
psychologisches experiment dass eine
fremde spezies mit der menschheit macht
ein wissenschaftler füttert den computer
mit immer mehr wissen von denen er
glaubt dass die fremde spezies sie
verbreitet hat und tatsächlich
irgendwann spuckt der computer das
ergebnis aus dass alles nur ein großes
experiment ist ab diesem moment vergeht
dem wissenschaftler das lachen weil das
geheimnis gelüftet ist sehr es mit einem
überlegenen computer einem verborgenen
rätsel auf die spur gekommen dass nur
mit einer solchen maschine zu lösen war
und diese maschine gibt es bereits der
quantencomputer noch macht eher fehler
aber er ist auf dem vormarsch und er
wird probleme lösen können die heute
noch unlösbar sind es war die sensation
im januar 2019 ibm beginnt damit den
erst
quantencomputer auf dem freien markt
anzubieten den ibm system one einen
quantencomputer mit 20 cubes die
abkürzung für quantenbits damit bricht
ein neues zeitalter an bis 2019 konnte
man sich schon über das web auf ibm
quantencomputer an einloggen und
rechenzeiten mieten
wer mit einem quantencomputer arbeiten
will muss sich allerdings mit den apps
also den application programming
interfaces beschäftigen den
programmierschnittstellen die von gm
bereitgestellt werden denn damit
quantencomputer ihre besondere fähigkeit
das extra schnelle rechnen entfalten
können funktioniert der datentransfer
über verschränkte teilchen die alles
gleichzeitig machen können weil die
quantenbits sich in einer super position
befinden diese cubes können aus den
unterschiedlichsten teilchen bestehen
zum beispiel ionen in einer ionenfalle
und diese nehmen nicht wie biz den
zustand null oder eins an also an und
aus sondern befinden sich in beiden
positionen und noch anderen mehr super
position bedeutet also dass sie sich in
allen möglichen zuständen gleichzeitig
befinden in einem gedankenexperiment des
physikers ernst rüdiger in dem eine
katze die hauptrolle spielt ist das sehr
gut beschrieben schuldigen das ganze
befindet sich in einem kasten
darin ist ein radioaktives teilchen
daneben ein geigerzähler er misst den
zerfall des teilchens zerfällt ist löst
der geigerzähler ein mechanismus aus der
ein gift frei setzt dass die katze tötet
allerdings befindet sich dieses teilchen
in der super position es hat alle
eigenschaften zwischen zerfall und nicht
zerfallen das heißt dass die katze so
lange tot und lebendig zugleich ist bis
der zustand des teilchens gemessen
sprich der kasten geöffnet wird
die überlagerung dieser zustände ist
selbst ein eigener zustand und das
betrifft alle möglichen
quanteneigenschaften wie zum beispiel
den spin also die drehrichtung um die
eigene achse
er kann rechts oder links herum laufen
und bei quanten in der super position
auch alle werte dazwischen einnehmen
deshalb rechnen konnten nicht 1+2 gleich
drei sondern xy gleichzeitig mit allen
möglichen ergebnissen ibm rechnet beim
kann
computer mit fortschritten bei der
lösung vieler komplexer probleme in der
medikamentenforschung für die
berechnungen in der logistik der
finanzwirtschaft bei künstlicher
intelligenz oder datensicherheit das
ibm-system wann ist ein wichtiger
schritt in richtung kommerzialisierung
des kranken computers dieses neue system
ist entscheidend für die erweiterung des
quantencomputers über die grenzen des
forschungslabors hinaus während wir an
der entwicklung praktischer quanten
anwendung für wirtschaft und
wissenschaft arbeiten so aber in
christina weiss präsident von hybrid
cloud und director von ibm research und
noch ein meilenstein erreichte das
quanten computing 2009 10 zum ersten mal
hat ein quantencomputer eine
rechenaufgabe mit offensichtlich
geringer fehlerquote gelöst für die ein
aktueller supercomputer rund 1,6
milliarden mal länger rechnen müsste
drei minuten und 20 sekunden statt
10.000 jahre benötigte ein google
quantencomputer für eine spezifische
aufgabe der google konten computer hat
53 cubes damit kann er knapp 1,6
milliarden zustände gleichzeitig
annehmen ein wahrer quantensprung im
quantencomputer
wir stehen vor einem neuen zeitalter der
informationstechnologie
das verrückte an dieser technologie ist
dass hier tatsächlich mit zuständen von
teilchen gearbeitet werden kann
die sich unserer alltagserfahrung
komplett entziehen und dennoch werden
sie dazu benutzt relevante berechnungen
für unsere alltagswelt anzustellen
quantencomputer sind nur ein aspekt
dieser neuen entwicklung ein anderer ist
das beamen von teilchen zum zwecke einer
informationsübertragung die absolut
abhörsichere verbindung ermöglicht und
eine solche verbindung ist jetzt auch
über das weltall gelungen das heißt wie
bei raumschiff enterprise ist zumindest
ein teilchen von der erde in den
weltraum und wieder zurück gepumpt
worden 2012 ist dem wiener professor
anton zeilinger zum ersten mal das
beamen über eine distanz von 143
kilometern gelungen telefonierte den
quantenzustand eines lichtteilchen eines
photons zwischen den kanarischen inseln
la palma und teneriffa
schon damals sagte er voraus dass damit
die möglichkeit der teleportation von
informationen zu satelliten bewiesen
was hat zeilinger gemacht nichts anderes
als die von albert einstein so
bezeichnete spukhafte verschränkung von
teilchen zu nutzen
es ist nämlich möglich zwei teilchen zu
erzeugen die exakt denselben
quantenzustand haben dieselbe
wellenfunktion diese teilchen sind
verschränkt wenn man sie jetzt trennt
bleiben sie dennoch miteinander
verbunden ihre zustände ändern sich
synchron egal wie weit sie voneinander
entfernt sind
in salingers experiment wurde ein photon
auf la palma behalten und das andere
nach teneriffa geschickt beide
lichtteilchen waren miteinander
verschränkt dann hat er das verbleibende
photon mit einem weiteren foto mit einer
anderen wellenfunktion verschränkt so
dass sich dessen wellenfunktion änderte
dasselbe passierte im selben moment mit
dem lichtteilchen auf der anderen insel
allerdings gibt es noch ein problem
teilchen gingen bei großen entfernung
verloren wurden absorbiert oder die
übertragung wurde anderweitig gestört
deswegen ist die teleportation von
quantenzuständen hier auf der erde über
große distanzen schwierig luftbewegung
wasserdampf rauchpartikel zum beispiel
machen sie bei größeren distanzen
unmöglich anders ist das bei satelliten
im weltall gibt es keine luft es
herrscht ein vakuum das haben sich
chinesische wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler zu nutze macht sie
schickten den satelliten matthäus vom
satelliten stadtzentrum york one in der
wüste gobi mit einer rakete vom typ
langer marsch 2c in eine sonnen
synchrone umlaufbahn auf der nachtseite
der erde
der satellit passierte so die
bodenstation in tibet jeden tag zum
dunkelsten zeitpunkt um mitternacht
ideal für kommunikation mit licht
innerhalb von 32 tagen schickten die
forschenden jede nacht 4000 verschränkte
photonen zum satelliten die kürzeste
distanz zwischen dem satelliten und der
bodenstation war dabei 500 kilometer und
die längste 1400 kilometer und sogar bei
der längsten entfernung klappte die
teleportation 911 mal gab es positive
ergebnisse die teleportation
wahrgenommen stolz heißt es wir melden
die erste quanten teleportation von
unabhängigen einzelne photonen kubitz
von einer bodenstation zu einem
satelliten in einer niedrigen umlaufbahn
überein
uplink kanal mit einer entfernung von
bis zu 1400 kilometern
der vorteil einer solchen kommunikation
ist ihre absolute abhörsicherheit wird
der zustand eines teilchens gemessen
wird es dadurch verändert das heißt es
ist unmöglich irgendwelche informationen
abzufangen ohne sie dabei zu verändern
der eigentliche empfänger merkt dass
sofort wenn in der hardware kein fehler
vorliegt die chinesen wenden das
verfahren schon in der praxis an seit
dem 18 kongress der kommunistischen
partei chinas ende 2012 erfahren die
westlichen geheimdienste nichts mehr
darüber was bei dem parteikongressen
insgeheim besprochen oder entschieden
wurde nichts dringt nach außen die
chinesen hatten einen kranken netzwerk
installiert und die kommunikation über
eine leitung verschränkt sie war absolut
abhörsicher aber was passiert mit der
information wenn sie durch einen
lauschangriff gestört wird dann bricht
sie zusammen und der lauschangriff wird
identifiziert weil in dem moment ja die
super position durch den lauschangriff
beendet wird und jetzt könnt ihr etwas
gutes tun bitte unterstützen diesen
schweren zeiten die buchhandlungen und
kauft das buch dort und hier geht es
weiter mit einem anderen video aus der
edition zukunft rowohlt verblüffende
erkenntnis die welt ist fraktal wieso
weshalb warum draufklicken und staunen
bis dann bleibt dran